[Applaudissements]
jugement et si c'était pas prévu comme
ça mais on va passer directement la
troisième un troisième pour jean-michel
de metric parce que là d'un seul coup là
le même homme défier il dit chez les
pats là je suis patron hockey alors
jean-michel je montrais le truc le plus
honteux que j'ai trouvé sur vous les
gens bichet qui est le plus fêtards de
nous tous le problème c'est que je ne
sais pas s'il se souvient de tous les
gens avec qui fait la bonne boulin le
problème c'est que s'en souviennent et
l'envoi des photos sur les réseaux
sociaux comme lors de ce retour de
deauville au petit matin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]